if you're a female who then goes on to
transition I have heard now from several
people who lived as females and then
transitioned that their libido went
through the roof they were shocked by it
they were disturbed by it most of them
said I get it now I'm looking at this
other person whether they're attracted
to men or women I can't stop thinking
about their body parts
I have been looking forward to speaking
to you for quite a while because you
shared an article by Chelsea Connor boy
in the New York Times called maternal
instinct is a myth that men created she
says that the maternal instinct is a
social construct generated and upheld by
the patriarchy to impel women to raise
children and keep them out of the
workforce however part way down you you
shared a quote that was quite revealing
I think this is from her new research on
the parental brain makes clear that the
idea of maternal instinct is something
innate automatic and distinctly female
is a myth one that has stuck despite the
best efforts of feminists to debunk it
from the moment it entered public
discourse all your thoughts on Chelsea
Connery's article Carol
well I have a lot to say uh most of it
is not good and I feel kind of bad about
that because Chelsea was probably pretty
excited about having her article in the
New York Times and she probably worked
really hard on it and I think her heart
is in the right place uh I think the
there are lots of Articles kind of like
this but this is one of the most
egregious example of this particular
kind of article maybe that I've ever
seen uh New York Times you know it's not
super surprising it was printed in that
particular Outlet
um but
so I said I think her heart is in the
right place and I guess I think that
people who write these kinds of Articles
especially from a kind of feminist point
of view are grasping at straws to find
something kind of real and biological
that will support the idea that uh women
should have equal rights and equal
opportunities you know relative to men
and well that goal may be laudable
actually I don't yeah well that goal may
be logical and we can talk about that
goal later
um what is not laudable and what really
bothers me as a scientist is the idea
that anyone believes and that
intelligent people are promoting the
idea that in order to secure anybody's
human rights whatever you think those
rights should be we have to basically
uh uh lie of course there's a maternal
Instinct you know we don't need to uh
kind of twist the facts of biology to
support anybody's rights we don't have
to distort reality we have to you know
we can tell the truth and fight for
people's rights those are different
things like what exists in nature is not
the same thing as what people's human
rights are we decide us humans we decide
what we want and what kind of society we
want regardless of the facts of Nature
and sort of I don't I think conflating
those two things is dangerous from many
uh perspectives but this is just also
blatantly false and pretty much
everybody knows it so it is like an
example of
um the emperor is actually not wearing
any clothes and nobody is saying so I
want to say so prove to me that maternal
Instinct isn't a myth that men created
okay did men so first of all it kind of
annoys me because it gives men a hell of
a lot of power men are very powerful but
you can't do that completely control how
you act we get to dictate how it is that
you interact with your children
yes and you get the rest of society to
believe something so stupid it's like
somehow you magic men have gotten us all
to believe that there is something
innate about moms wanting to care for
their children in a way that is
different and more intense than the way
that fathers do so I can you know one
way to try to prove it to you is to just
take human culture out of the mix look
at every
um mammal that is not EX exposed to
human culture well not even exposed but
look at every non-human mammal and the
females are the ones in 95 of those
mammals who uh
are the sole providers of any kind of
Parental care for their offspring of
course they have an instinct of course
that is part of being a mammal and
there's only five percent of mammals or
or even a smaller percent uh in which
the males contribute any parental care
humans are one of those species that's
part of what makes us really interesting
but males have the choice to invest in
their kids the kids can survive without
them the father they typically cannot at
least in a natural environment or an
ancestral environment uh it would be
very tough for them to survive without
their mother and uh so yes there's a
difference between men and women in the
degree to which we invest in our
Offspring not only do we have the
um comparison with non-human animals we
have mechanisms we know what some of
these mechanisms are hormonal and
neurological that contribute to maternal
care and I mean I could go on and on
about the science and there's just
nothing
bad about this you know it's great that
fathers invest in their kids it's great
that moms can have the choice to invest
less than their our partners you know
moms can go out and go to work that's
what I did I you know had somebody else
took care of my baby for the most part
during the day while I was at work I
pumped my milk but if I didn't want to
pump my milk or you know have a deep
desire it's not men didn't give me that
desire I mean that idea is sort of
insulting to me it sounds like
you may have been one of the poster
children poster women for someone that
was liberated from this maternal at
least in terms of the restriction on
their ability to continue with their
career and research and stuff that
you're doing at Harvard it seems like
yeah you would be a flag waving card
carrying person for that and yet still
don't believe it
um
yeah it is something I did I didn't
really want to do that I wish I could
have stayed home
with Griffin uh who's now 13
um for much you know for a year rather
than a few months and he was close by so
I did get to
take off my shoes and run a couple
blocks to um
breastfeed him like three times a day
which was great and most moms do not get
to do that and that's really painful for
them because they have a maternal
Instinct it's painful if your breasts
are full of milk and you have to you
know have a machine squeeze it out
rather than having your kids lips suck
it out I imagine it's also quite painful
just to run if you've got breasts that
are full of milk and you're jogging down
the street just generally it's it's
challenging
well I I also saw it but I didn't feel
the pain because I was so motivated
you're so maternally so maternally uh
pushed by the patriarchy a great
response to this uh that was done in
Colette according to this view the
parental brain is essentially a blank
slate filled with expectations
experiences chiefly dictated by social
expectations for women and men in other
words women's and men's parental brains
and Associated behaviors would be the
same with the right social mores and
behavioral expectations as he says
pretty much all uh mammals uh the men
don't have any uh male parental
Investments the claim fails to consider
that males do very little parenting in
the vast majority of animals especially
those including humans in which males
compete intensely for status as it
happens humans are among the exceptions
to this pattern men invest considerably
more in children than do the males of
our closest relatives chimpanzees and
bonobos who are uniformly deadbeats
later in the article he said brain
patterns can be used to correctly
identify whether the owner is a man or a
woman with 93 to 96 accuracy
have you seen this yes yes okay but that
there so can I sit just make two
responses there so one is I the other
aim of the article which I really did
think was important and it was too bad
that this particular goal got weighed
down with all this kind of crap science
um the goal was to show
the ways in which society
has
um in some ways because there are or
there are thought to be but in reality
there are these biological differences
the authors seem to think that this has
given license to men in particular to
um help to create policies and
expectations that limit women's ability
to do what they want to do whether they
want to you know what kind of parent
they want to be how uh invested they
should be in parenting so that's a good
goal right just because we have a uh
maternal Instinct doesn't mean that we
should do anything in particular it
doesn't even mean we should have kids or
that we should be the ones to stay home
with them but that's a separate Point
um from whatever the science says about
maternal Instinct so that was
um thing one thing yes the naturalistic
fallacy presuming that because something
existed in nature that it's something
which is laudable and desirable in the
modern world I wish that we could just
dispense with that entire line of
argumentation every single time that I
see it I go right okay men used to fight
for dominance physically we have laws
that stop you from punching people in
the street even if you both see the same
attractive woman in front of you right
like obviously obviously no one thinks
that this is the case my main problem
with this
war on motherhood war on the
pedestalization of mothers as mothers
and the assumption that if you are a
mother that decides to stay home and
build a family while your partner goes
to work that you've been rubed into
doing this by the patriarchy that you're
somehow a second-class citizen to me
saying you can do whatever you want yes
but if you're to say the maternal
instinct is a myth that men created the
subtext to that is if you fell for it
you're an idiot woman yes yes
that is a great uh
example about why this kind of article
that appears so often and in kind of
liberal Outlets is so damaging because
yes this is something that is natural
basically natural there's a lot of
variation in how it's going to be
expressed but there's nothing wrong with
getting you know gaining immense
pleasure from devoting yourself to
something that is natural if it gives
you pleasure and that's what you choose
and if it doesn't hurt anybody else you
know there's no reason to stigmatize
that as though you know you're just
doing what men want you to do but then
there's the issue about whether you can
tell male and female brains apart
so my understanding is that what you
just said is totally correct that human
beings scientists say can't just look at
brains
um say under a mic you know a little
area is necessarily and figure out what
um which are male and which are female
but that uh machine learning can do that
with a really high degree of accuracy
it does appear that there are
um systemic differences in the brain
that differentiate male and female
brains on average there's you know a
fair amount of overlap and variation but
we have different brains one question is
whether it is so one challenge to that
is that it's life experience that leads
to these differences you know if they
exist then it's all due to the
patriarchy and that uh that leads men
you know to behave in certain ways and
interacting socially in certain ways and
because they're you're performing
masculinity in society that performance
and the reception to that performance is
going to condition your brain to develop
uh in different ways from a woman's
brain you know and there may be there is
I think some truth to that but I don't
think there's any way that explains uh
male female brain differences on average
we also have lifetime difference is in
exposure to testosterone and estrogen
those steroid hormones also have lasting
impacts on brain organization starting
extremely early on in fetal development
so yes Society is important yes Society
you know just like we see with maternal
Instinct there's an initial difference
there that is shaped you know that
difference is then then plays out in
modern society in all kinds of ways and
if men if the patriarchy whatever you
think that is can somehow exploit female
labor maybe that happens but that
doesn't mean that this difference
doesn't exist or isn't innate in some
way I wonder if Chelsea conoboy has kids
uh based on the women that I've spoken
to who have had kids
once that uh hormone Cascade gets
released it's a hell of a ride and it's
a hell of a way for you to stop all of
the progesterone for men even you know
like Vassar pressing getting released
baby lying on the chest why is it that
when you pass a baby's head around
everyone wants to take a nice big whiff
of it like what do you think is going on
here even though that's even the women
that aren't that haven't given birth and
that maybe aren't even genetically
related that are just doing the whole
aloe parenting the modern version of
aloe parenting stuff now like yes
it blows my mind that people can be so
a ostensibly pro-female
and obviously anti-mother
that blows my mind
yeah that's I I don't even know where to
begin I completely agree with you one
thing that I do when I teach my class on
and I we get into the sex differences
part and we talk about
um sexual development like how over are
um
developmental trajectory we become male
and female and then what happens in
puberty and how the hormones work on our
bodies and on our brains
we have different they're different
aspects of our environment that are
Salient to us so men are much more
likely to stare at women's breasts and
that when they're walking down the
street or you know any any cues of
female fertility uh those vary by
culture but there are some that are
pretty standard and so I if I do look at
a woman's breasts it's out of some sort
of competition or I'm trying to evaluate
my own sexual competition is showing
Carol something like that yeah so if a
guy does it it's for a you know a mating
purposes and and sort of paying
attention to what's in the environment
that might be reproductively beneficial
to him women are much more likely and I
do this
um and I just hit menopause at 56. um so
when I see somebody with a baby go by I
just cannot I'm one of those women you
just described I love babies I want to
smell them I kind of want to like take a
bite of some baby fat or something and
it's they're so attractive and they've
oh I've always loved that of course
there are some women who don't like
babies who don't ever want kids but what
we're talking about is patterns on
average we pay attention to those
aspects of our environment environmental
stimuli that we evolve to pay attention
to and
um so I think you're totally right
though that's evidence that the fact
that these patterns exist across the
planet and in chimpanzees little like
adolescent chimpanzee females especially
want to get in on the baby action when
there is a baby around
um and that's something males are much
less likely to do
what does testosterone do why do we have
it
to help you men convert energy into
Offspring men yes
my friend Bridget halfway through her
show all the time just screams the word
women I'm just gonna start going men
wait fantasy yeah
okay
um yeah that's what it's for it's a
reproductive hormone it's not all about
sex it's about
how like the same thing as estrogen it
is about first of all the physical stuff
you've got to have
your penis and testicles and vas
deferens and everything you need to you
know produce your sperm and ejaculate
right but imagine having all that stuff
and not being attracted to not you know
wanting to use it basically
um imagine not having all of the
Weaponry but none of the motivation
yeah like in a red deer I wrote in my
book about Red Deer they grow these huge
weapons on their heads every season only
during the height of the Mating Season
the height of the rut and they
testosterone is what helps to promote
that growth and the sharp antlers and
the
um velvet coating coming off but if they
didn't have any desire if they just like
walked around being friendly to every
other male
that would just never happen Evolution
doesn't give you weapons and sperm and
then no desire to use it I'm right in
saying that the males that grow these
antlers during the rut when they're
trying to mate with the females they're
friends they're with their mates being
much more docile and much more chill
yes that's what's so cool about seasonal
breeders and this is why I went to study
to Scotland to to hang out with the um
Red Deer during the rut because humans
aren't seasonal breeders you guys are
just masculinized you have puberty I
mean you're even masculinized as kids
you have Rough and Tumble play you're
different than girls on average again
tons of variation so you can't really
see the effects of testosterone the way
you can in a seasonal breeder that is
super chill with his you know bachelor
mates right they hang out and they're
friendly outside of breeding season they
don't have weapons they're not making
sperm because there's no females who can
get pregnant they're like let's all get
along once the females become fertile
and they get a whiff of her they really
want to accumulate not that their
possessions because the females can
leave but they want to accumulate a
harem because they want to have a lot of
sex with a lot of females that's what
they're driven to do in order to do it
they have have to really fight and beat
their competitors and the ones who have
the best antlers and our biggest and
strongest and most fierce and who scare
the other ones off because they're
roaring all the time and like literally
parading around and showing how big and
strong they are they're the ones who
have the most sex and the other lonely
ones up in the hills above are just
watching the dominant males with the big
harems just do thinking like how can I
get in here do I have the balls to
literally you know to challenge him and
most of them never will and they won't
they'll die without you know producing
any kids so I don't even remember how we
got into that oh okay what does
testosterone do that's what it does but
you can't see it in human males as much
because you guys are always basically
horny and oh you know have a baseline
higher propensity for physical
aggression it doesn't just come and go
so dramatically like in all these
seasonal breeders so just to answer your
question it helps you
have the physical capacity in terms of
muscle mass in terms of sperm in terms
of strength in terms of ability to get
an erection and it coordinates all that
stuff with what you need psychologically
and behaviorally which is increased
propensity to take physical risks to be
competitive with other males whether
that requires the physical risks or not
if you can't get in a bar fight you're
going to go play football or basketball
or whatever sport you do and you're
going to want to be the best at that
sport because that really helps you
dominance wise girls like that you're
also going to compete in terms of your
profession and you're going to be
ambitious and it coordinates all that
stuff because that's what you have to do
to maximize your reproduction and it
helps you be a good dad by going down
when you have a baby so and that's also
what we see in non-human animals it's
not all about going and getting as many
females as possible it's about being a
devoted partner and father because if
you can have one female's reproductive
output
um and you can invest in those kids and
ensure their survival that could be just
as good if not better a strategy
depending on your status and your
abilities than going out on the open
market and trying to compete and maybe
you get somebody pregnant maybe you
don't if you have uh one mate and you
invest in her uh and the kids then that
can be really successful strategy and
that requires lower testosterone for a
while does that mean that men who have
high testosterone uh higher in state of
seeking Behavior
no it means so really the individual
differences in testosterone in men
within the health and normal range
predict very little if uh about libido
or physical aggression or anything else
it's really about the changes that you
experience throughout the day throughout
the seasons base and it's all in
response to what your environment is
your social environment in particular so
those changes are meaningful and that
the changes that you have when you have
a kid or what when it goes down are
meaningful because you're in an
environment where care for your
Offspring really helps you
reproductively and you have the smell of
your kid you have the sight of your kid
you have your partner there all if you
didn't have that stuff that change in
testosterone and probably do nothing
what about depression
does testosterone relate to that at all
yeah it does seem to
um so one interesting
finding about testosterone is that when
females transition to uh live as men and
they're going through a gender
transition they a lot of them report
that their mood improves and not
apparently just because they're happy
that they're actually transitioning
um because we see the same thing in men
there's certain forms of depression in
men who have relatively low testosterone
that seems to improve in some men when
they are supplemented with testosterone
and uh so there is a link there I don't
think it's very well understood but it
does there are also in
um trans men they say often that when
they have their testosterone injection
if that's how they're getting it that
they get a mood Boost from that and then
that wanes kind of over time this would
make sense because women on average are
more uh neurotic than men
what's the personality trait eroticism
yeah the higher neuroticism than males
are yeah all right I really want you to
get into this what happens when females
go on testosterone how do they report
alterations in their experience of life
foreign
so what was puberty like for you
fantastic
why because I could get an erection with
a gust of wind that was at the right
angle
and you didn't mind that okay of course
I did it was just hilarious I just found
it absolutely hilarious
okay but so you got a lot of erections
were you would you say that
uh that was correlated with any
psychological state of mind I had an
obsession with the Spice Girls for quite
a while uh that was like okay that was a
hot thing for me and there was five of
them as well so it was like a variety
pack but that's so funny I know uh but
yeah I mean you're constantly thinking
about sex uh I think you begin to or at
least I was more attuned to status as
well uh interesting yeah yeah I finally
actually started to realize what kind of
a social hierarchy was going on but yeah
I mean the the prevalent thing was what
was going on between my legs
yeah so obviously girls are also increa
get having an increase in libido but the
number one psychological change you know
in addition to feeling an Ascent you
know for a lot of people obviously an
increased sense of freedom to express
who they are but the the number one
psychological change is a again and
there's variance here and that's
important today you don't need to
present caveat yeah everybody knows
everyone that's listening is reasonable
and they have got sick of me saying on
average enough they know thank you I
just yeah have
been on the receiving end of people
saying well I didn't that didn't happen
to me and yeah this is all on average
from here on out so the the number one
change people experience is this
for a woman for somebody who's been
living as a woman a really
sort of overpowering and even shocking
obsession with sex because it's not the
especially for
um females who transition later in life
and they are used to being the target of
sexual you know intense uh sexual desire
and even a lot of these people are
lesbians and they have resented the way
that men have looked at them or looked
at their breasts obviously you know a
lot of women do resent that but if
you're a female who then goes on to
transition I have heard now from several
uh trans men people who lived as females
and then transitioned that their libido
went through the roof they were shocked
by it they were disturbed by it some
um felt that this is okay because this
is what it's like to be live as a man
but most of them said I get it now I'm
looking at this other person whether
they're attract did two men or women I'm
attracted to their butt I'm attracted to
their boobs I can't stop thinking about
their body parts and they described
having a change in their patterns of
Attraction where when they were living
and I'm not even making this up it's so
it sounds like such a stereotype but
when they were living as women the
target of their attraction was a whole
person like that it was much more about
the whole human being in relationship to
them and then on male levels of
testosterone it was like more
objectified and the target of their
sexual attraction was more objectified
it didn't prevent intimacy but there was
a whole other aspect to sexuality that
um opened up so that is the number one
thing that people have said and they
said it gives them a huge amount of
insight into men and empathy for men
because this is something that they have
to deal with and learn how to deal with
socially and and women are just like
you're you know think that guys are just
being [ __ ] when they
um might look at their breasts or
something and yes you know guys should
not look like stare at women's breasts
in ways that make them uncomfortable but
it is something that uh women don't
really understand because we're not like
staring at guys penises or something a
lot like that's just not a thing and
that's why men don't wear clothes
generally where you know their outline
of their penis is showing because we
don't really want to see that I would
guess my very small amount of exposure
to the gay cruising scene is that yes
men do tend to wear outfits that allow
themselves to be objectified more easily
that is right that's right because
um that's what men want they know that
moments yeah it's not what women want
and they know how to advertise what they
have to other men and and gay men don't
have women like putting on the brakes
and telling them what their sexuality
needs to be be like they can just
everybody already gets it they're
already men and I think that's great you
know there's must be a lot of freedom in
that of based on my friends that talk to
me about cruising grounds without as
soon as you remove the gatekeeper from a
sexual interaction there's all Hell
Breaks Loose so yes it seems like a
basically just a failure of cross-sex
mind reading this sort of
objectification concern we don't really
understand what's going on that's not to
say that there aren't men out there who
don't cross the line blah blah blah I
remember I had a conversation with David
Buss who can use this example where he
said um if there was a pair of rocks on
a beach that looked quite a bit like
boobs the man would look at the rocks
and think right pretty nice pretty nice
rack you've got there Madam and my point
being that men will objectify pretty
much anything they have am I right in
saying they have a purpose-built reward
mechanism for looking at things that are
sexually gratifying as well
yes I mean there's a whole interesting
dopamine
um circuit there so that testosterone
appears to condition a
um dopamine rise when there's
reproductively Salient stimulate in the
environment so it um encourages an
Adaptive response to whether it's
aggressive or sexual or for women
breastfeeding or you know maternally
oriented and I should just say just to
get back quickly to the maternal
Instinct there are some studies that
show that women who have postpartum
depression who feel like they don't have
a maternal Instinct tend not to have the
same dopamine increase around
um when an oxytocin goes up for
breastfeeding it usually conditions this
dopamine rise and women who report not
having a maternal Instinct don't have
that same dopamine rise they desperately
want to but they feel like I don't
really
care if this kid you know I'm not
motivated to have to breastfeed this kid
so yeah I think that testosterone does
condition men to respond and this is of
course Society can
um exaggerate or nudge around the
expression of these differences but yeah
of course there are these differences we
pay attention to different things there
seems to be you know to me there's tons
of evidence that it is differences in
sex hormones over the lifetime that set
us on these different trajectories
um
do you think that women can appreciate
what sex drive is like for a man without
going through a short course of
testosterone and getting jacked at the
same time
I think I in writing the book and just
talking to so many men I mean it has
taken a huge amount of work for me
I I always do this I get very
emotional about this um and I've I've
met some people have given me a hard
time for that because I'm not being a
good feminist or something
I'm not man-hating enough
um shame on you
no but I really I mean it's okay it's
funny it's about sex but it's also kind
of tragic because I feel like
this is what nature this these are the
ways that nature has shaped men it's
easy for women to and and I understand
and I have been angry myself about the
way that men sometimes behave
um what I don't even know what what did
you ask me is it possible is it possible
for women to under yeah so no I guess I
do feel like I have
and understanding and You're gonna laugh
but I had a dream I had a dream when I
was writing the book
that I felt this kind of Attraction I
think it was to a woman's body
um just like standing around in the
kitchen this was in the dream
and I in the dream felt like how can I
like she was just a problem standing in
the way of me being able to touch her
body and I had to figure out I was like
so drawn to her body and I had to figure
out how to deal with her to get to the
body and it was a really strong drive
and I felt it only in the dream and when
I woke up I felt like oh my God this
must be it it must be that women are
almost standing in the way of men being
able to have their bodies and I felt
like I get it and if that's what
testosterone is doing I feel bad for the
men because in the dream I knew it was
wrong and bad of me to not pay attention
to this woman but it was like I had to
have the body and it was almost like
food and I was starving and I had to
have it that's and I just felt like oh
my God if that's it then I feel really
bad for everybody judging
that is a nice summation it's a nice
summation of of what it's like I think
the male sex drive really does seem to
have been pathologized I think uh in
recent years and I spend a good bit of
time in the gym and I find it as
interesting to watch other guys when
girls in gym leggings walk past
because I get to see this Mexican wave
of eyeballs
like everybody will turn and look all of
the guys have just I'm in between sets
or I'm doing whatever or someone will be
talking to their friend and they'll be
looking at their friend like that just
over their show
staring past them as some girl walks
past in the distance and I I understand
the point that you're trying to make
there about the fact that you are
castigating men for an innate inbuilt
reward mechanism that they didn't choose
to have
and saying that anything close to acting
on that is toxic masculinity and it is
you being part of a patriarchal
superstructure that's oppressively
keeping women down and blah blah blah
and there is basically nothing else
that I think we would get to at this
stage of modern society where
someone's innate preferences
would be treated with so much distaste
you know why why would it be the case
that the way someone is built can you
imagine if you said this to somebody
that's gay
to say well yeah look you know you've
got this particular uh yeah but I oh
yeah but I think the reason is you know
because of sexual assault and sexual
violence and just male violence in
general and you just happen to be
a member of the group that's responsible
for all that bad stuff uh so I think
it's different than like maternal
instinct or being gay because it's you
know when taken to an extreme or if left
unchecked then we're all in trouble
because it's powerful and kind of scary
um however any woman could have been
born male and so I don't see why women
get to be so judgy because if if any of
the women who are saying who are
throwing around this term toxic
masculinity if they were born male would
they what would they do how do they even
know what it's like to be a man they
they don't
um and that is Step One is to understand
what is going on and to try to listen
and have some empathy
can you explain the changes in orgasm
quality duration and Sensation that
people go through when they have to I'm
not making this up this was you right
that had a look at some of this stuff
yeah I just I have to say here
especially I know that there's variation
because I've people have told me who
have transitioned that they don't have
these kinds of orgasms but according to
the literate the scientific literature
and most of the people I've talked to
this is the case and I did not know I
feel uh that I should have known this
before I did not know that men and women
have a really different
um I mean obviously the orgasmic
experiences is different because men
have a penis and women have a vagina but
what I didn't know is that
a woman's orgasm is much more likely to
be a longer lasting full body
uh experience the men's orgasm is more
likely to have more intensity at the
peak but be uh shorter lived and more
localized to the genitalia like to that
area that is on average and I've had a
couple trans more than a couple trans
people tell me they prefer and even a
trans woman who de-transitions so she
went from living as a woman
to then living as a man with high
testosterone for four years fully
masculinized looked you know a hundred
percent like a man and then she
de-transitioned so she was able to talk
about what it's like to be live as a man
as a woman
um if that makes sense she said she
likes the orgasms off of testosterone
and uh appreciates the
um access to her full range of emotions
that she felt was limited on
testosterone and this is also consistent
with the scientific literature were you
on Joe Rogan recently
okay so I was also on and we both cried
a fair amount and we talked about crying
okay he is this very Matt really like
really masculine guy he takes a lot of
testosterone and he was bawling his
balling his eyes out that is unusual so
going on testosterone usually stops or
like really greatly reduces crying
um and coming off it
um
increases crying back to sort of typical
female levels which are much much higher
than male levels
um
yeah you only asked about orgasms but I
think uh it's that full body kind of
emotional experience that is associated
with more of an emotional connection
more access to a wide range of emotions
and I'll just say that
people describe and again the literature
suggests this is true that going on
testosterone makes it harder for men to
access these emotions except for anger
it's not that anger necessarily goes up
it's that out of all the emotions that
is one that is most easily uh accessed
that's interesting have you heard the uh
quote I think it's schopenhauer or
nature or someone that says after
copulation the devil's laughter can be
heard and what he's talking about is
post-nut Clarity or kind of the oh my
God
yes post-coital depression that some men
deal with
sorry
post I hope my students see this
because they taught me
in this uh was this is pacifier
um so they gave talks they gave it was a
seminar and they were giving little
talks and someone joked at the end of
the talk about post-nut Clarity and I
love my students and we have close
relationships and um
so I had no idea
I had no idea what that was
um and he explained it to me and all the
students were like yeah everyone knows
what that is
um yeah and it makes sense does your
viewers I assume know what post not
Clarity is I think so but I mean I'm
gonna guess is that a male phenomenon do
women have post-nut clarity
um
I imagine I mean if they're drunk or
something then you know when it actually
happens then of one here Carol you come
on
um
I don't think so I don't know okay so I
I feel right for me but I and I I'm
probably pretty typical
um I think that could be no I think
because men are much more willing to
lower whatever their standards or their
uh so I think another another element of
it is that uh posts this is total bro
signs right but come with me here okay
uh yeah postcardly
it makes sense for a woman to try and
pair bond more with the guy than the
other way around that's not to say that
men shouldn't pair bond with with the
woman but there is a greater need if the
woman has just given up one of the main
risk factors that she can in her entire
life it makes more sense for so whatever
the harsh light of the pillow or
whatever you want to call it
um having seen that as a man may make
you think okay let's just reassess my
options here do I really want to stick
about with this particular woman or
should I see if there's something a
little bit better out there maybe I
should consider my status seeking maybe
I should think about my position within
the hierarchy or other things that I've
got going on that are going to release a
ton of vasopress and another [ __ ]
because maybe I need to do that in order
there's maybe as a kid here in nine
months time and I gotta get myself to
the top of the the tree with regards to
this there are a lot more dynamics that
I can think of that would encourage a
man to not be all fluffy and nice after
sex
and would have this done have a period
of evaluation yes yes after sex yeah I
mean it does remind me a bit of
the period of evaluation after birth you
know in many natural fertility societies
for women where there is this period
where there may not be a strong bond
because it may not make sense for the
mother you know this would be an
infanticide situation where it can be
adaptive in some I mean that's very very
harsh to say but if the mother cannot
take care for whatever reason of her
child and she wants the chance to have
another one then In some cultures and
hunter-gatherers that kid is just left
if maybe there's uh
has a birth defect or uh you know but
there's a period where it's easier to do
that kind of before you feel bonded to
the other human being I read a story
about uh Charles Darwin and I think
Darwin ended up having 10 or 12 children
with his cousin actually uh and
beforehand he's doing this marriage pros
and cons list and in one of the
potential cons he actually right right I
saw that yeah yeah but he highlights the
potential issue which actually he ends
up encountering which is that if he has
children maybe some of them will die and
if they died then it would be sad and he
ends up losing I want to say maybe
two to four of his kids and I remember
learning about the different ages that
some of his children died at and I I
will have got some of these wrong but
broadly it's right one in a toddler
range like a two to three year old one
around about 10 to 11 and then another
one in the teens and
the author was making a justification
for why losing a child around the age of
10 or 11 is the most painful age that
you could lose them at and I was
thinking to myself well maybe it's
because you've spent so much time with
them that you've sort of got to love
them and maybe it's when they're a
little bit older you feel like well at
least they lived a little bit of a life
or whatever and life got cut short and
you know the three-year-old maybe you
haven't had enough time to bond and blah
blah blah and he was like that would be
the nice justification at the front of
your brain realistically what you've
realized as a father or a mother is I
got this child just about to the point
at which they could procreate and I
could be a grandfather optimizer and
it's failed and that's why his 10 year
old daughter's death was the most
painful one so devastating yeah no that
makes sense
um
and that when I I lived in Uganda for
eight months and I remember one of the
women there saying the saying that the
reason they had so many kids is because
you can expect a couple of them to die
you know you one or two are going to die
if they have 10 or however many kids
um so there's a different psychology
around parenting when you're not sure
about when the conditions are are
tougher than they are today and you know
I don't I only have the one kid and so I
put a hell of a lot of energy into him
um
yeah
is sex a spectrum
don't give me that look
uh I'm just as a big change
um it is not no it's not uh the traits
associated with sex can be on the
Spectrum but sex itself is not on a
spectrum do and it doesn't have to be
you can still males and females can
express themselves however they want it
doesn't have to be limited by their sex
but yeah there's only two
do intersex people disprove this
uh oh it's not just okay first of all
you have to Define what intersex is this
is a term that is thrown around a lot
and statistics are thrown around and uh
the idea is that there's all of these
people who are neither male nor female
and that is just not true I mean there
are
and exceeding there's
0.02 percent of people who have genetic
traits that uh don't match their sex so
they may have
um something that looks like a vagina
even though they're male
uh for instance or they might have
something that looks like a penis even
though they're female but even in those
very rare cases they're still male or
female so intersex doesn't really mean
having no sex or not being male nor
female there's exceedingly rare cases
much smaller than 0.02
of people who have gonadal tissue of
both sexes and there we may not know
whether they're male or female or you
might not even be able to say uh but
that doesn't mean that we're not a
species with two Sexes like almost every
uh like all mammals for instance and
vertebrates almost all there's two Sexes
we cannot change sex there are other
species that have two Sexes but can't
they might be uh simultaneous
hermaphrodites or they might be
sequential hermaphrodites but they still
have male and female but mammals and
most vertebrates are not that kind we
only have male and female and we can't
change our sex over the lifetime but the
point there is it really doesn't matter
for most things some things like maybe
prison cells or sports teams you know
where bodies really matter then sex
matters and then we have a right to know
what kind of what sex we're dealing with
but this scientific fact should not
limit
anybody's ability to express themselves
that is the point and we don't need to
pretend that there aren't two sexes in
order to try to support again anybody's
rights and I just this drives me crazy
because it's destroying science and the
scientific method and it's
um not taking us in the right direction
in my view
rolling the lifespan forward a little
bit
what about Behavior differences in boys
and girls that are toddlers I'm gonna
guess that testosterone plays less of a
role at this stage than it would do when
you look at an adult male and an adult
female or am I wrong
I I you might be wrong
um it's you know I'm not sure how to
quantify but what's amazing about
childhood is that in the the huge
differences we see between girls and
boys
um is that those come about
because of differential exposure to
testosterone in utero and shortly after
birth so male babies have the spike of
testosterone for a few months after
they're born and it is permanently
changing the brain and I guess the
reason I think that's so important is
because this occurs so early in life
and it occurs
I'm gonna say despite
the efforts of uh despite socialization
because there are a lot of kids who are
gender non-conforming there are a lot of
say boys who are gonna grow up to be gay
who don't have those typical masculine
characteristics as kit as a kid they
don't uh enjoy like tackling their
friends and they want to hang out with
girls and they want to do more talking
and they want smaller groups and
a lot of those kids parents are trying
to socialize them as like typical boys
right and those kids are getting bullied
by their boy peers especially and they
can't help it that's who they are you
know they're a little bit more
effeminate or a lot more uh effeminate
than a typical boy so I do not buy that
kids are socialized into
um these different types of behavior
there's just no evidence for that and it
parallels what we see in non-human
animals where
um male juvenile chimpanzees are more
active and more physical and prefer more
Rough and Tumble play male you know rats
are the ones who like to tackle each
other and have Rough and Tumble play and
it looks like it's fun for them and you
can manipulate that
um Rough and Tumble play by changing
testosterone exposure so you can take a
female rat and give her testosterone
um in the perinatal period and she'll
play like a boy you can take a boy rat
and deprive him of testosterone and
he'll play like a girl and this makes
sense because this is a reproductive
strategy that boys are practicing or
male animals are practicing through play
it's male male competition you got to
learn how to compete physically you got
to learn what the cues are you learn
when to back off and it has to be fun or
else you're not going to do it and this
is an important skill for male
reproduction and then we know in humans
that girls who are exposed to higher
than average levels of testosterone are
more like uh are masculinized their play
is masculinized they are they prefer boy
toys more than girls who don't have high
testosterone they have you know they're
more likely to prefer Rough and Tumble
play so so we see the same thing in
humans as we see in non-human animals so
that I think is strong those sex
differences I think are really important
because they haven't those kids haven't
grown up in society yet they haven't
experienced the patriarchy or whatever
you know I don't like the word actually
the patriarchy but they haven't
experienced all as much gender
socialization which there is a huge
amount in every culture uh so the fact
that we see those differences so young I
think is really powerful evidence
um that testosterone shapes them you
know and they're similar to what other
animals do it's like that uh Chelsea
Connolly where she said uh uh one that
has stuck around despite the best
efforts of feminists to debunk it from
the moment it entered public discourse
that's what I'm dealing with the best
efforts of feminists to debunk like a
lot of what I'm saying but it keeps
coming back up it's all it's almost like
it's inbuilt almost like it's inbuilt
are there any are there any correlations
or
relationships between testosterone and
gender identity or sexual preference
yeah there aren't a lot there aren't a
lot so what's interesting about men
[Music]
is like we were talking about before
so gay men
are very masculine in terms of their uh
sexual psychology right they're sort of
just typical men except they want to
have sex with other men I mean that's
the only difference really in terms of
the sexual psychology so that's a very
masculine phenotype so
and that's one of the main things
testosterone does is condition that male
sexuality right so just from that
evidence I wouldn't expect there to be
any lack of testosterone along the way
and there isn't that we know of
what is interesting is there are other
differences
in um gay men on average that have to do
with uh some ways in which they're
feminized in terms of like occupational
interests
um physical aggression and so it's
possible there's some
timing difference in testosterone
exposure or something in utero but I
there's no evidence for that
um
and then in women there's some evidence
that increased testosterone in utero has
masculinizing effects on gender identity
so this is the same population of people
I was talking about before who have
congenital adrenal hyperplasia where
they have high testosterone in utero but
it's normalized at Birth
um so even they go through a normal
female puberty they're still more likely
to be lesbians more likely to have a
male gender identity
uh so there seems to be some effect in
females but
um we don't necessarily see the same
thing in males and the the data on the
females is not super
convincing to me why
because there are plenty of uh lesbians
who don't have congenital adrenal
hyperplasia and the we just don't have
the ability to collect really good data
on uh prenatal testosterone period we
have like the 2D 40 which you might have
heard of
um there's some evidence that lesbians
might have more masculinized 2D 40s but
I'm not super convinced by that
I learned from Christina Durante if you
know her
yeah I know her name yes so she did a
really cool study where she got an actor
to read a Hollywood script uh this guy
was trained one of the characters that
he played was a bad boy and the bad boy
had a twin and the twin was a nerd but
they were both the same guy the same guy
reading a different script with a
different hairdo and whatever and they
brought women in it was to check about
ovulatory cycle attraction and whether
or not women would presume that the bad
boy was actually a better long-term mate
Prospect what are the sort of words that
they used to describe him are they
saying things like they think that he
would clean up around the house and be a
good father and so on and so forth and
does this change based on whether they
are or not ovulating but the most
interesting thing and she just threw it
away is this flippant line she didn't
just study straight women
she studied gay women as well they
brought gay women in yeah to speak to
this guy and I was saying well look like
if you're not attracted to the guy
presumably the gay women just didn't
make any difference no they did it did
and she said and I was like well you
know one of the examples was
one of the girls said to the bad boy she
was ovulating what one of the girls said
to the bad boy I'm going away to Vegas
uh this weekend with my friend whereas
to the nerd she said I'm going away to
Vegas this weekend with my boyfriend so
little things that had speak a lesbian
said that no no no no this is the the
straight woman right so you had these
very yeah more obvious more conscious
sort of even though it's probably still
subconscious
I'm not out there obvious display of
whatever you want to call it like make
mate uh anonymity or whatever however
they looked at non-verbal cues as well
stuff like body language stuff like
playing with their hair and the lesbian
women who were ovulating were showing
more non-verbal cues of flirting to the
guy who was a sex that they are not
attracted to sexually
I thought that was so so interesting
it's interesting but I am always
skeptical of findings from one study
because I don't know anything about the
study it sounds amazing but it is
consistent with the idea that female
sexuality is more flexible than male
sexuality and more fluid
um significantly more bisexual women
than there are bisexual men yes yes yes
and that you know women you know about
the studies showing that when men watch
pornography their penis tells the truth
basically so if a guy says I am
um heterosexual then if he's telling the
truth he gets an erection only to in
response to pornography that shows a man
and a woman and he really is not aroused
when he sees two men
um interacting sexually so
if a woman says I'm heterosexual
your vagina will lubricate but it's not
it's the vaginal photoplathysmograph
which which measures blood flow to the
vagina the guy uses say that again
so the what the scientists do is they
put a little ring around the guy's penis
yes and as the circumference increases
so it gets harder you know blood flow to
the penis that's the
um penile plethysmograph can will be con
um consistent with his subjective
reports of how it turned on he is if
he's telling the truth so and guys
who say their heterosexual actually do
show then
um objective arousal to
the heterosexual stimulate whereas women
who say they're heterosexual
will it's the um vaginal
photoplathysmograph which is this glass
tube that works on light refraction so
as the vagina is engorged with blood
that is taken as an index of sexual
arousal
um she will get this to all sexual
stimuli including bonobos having sex
whereas the men
um and that's in relation to watching
some boring like travel documentary or
something that's the control kind of
evidence showing that that female
sexuality is in fact more fluid and then
we have all this behavioral evidence uh
and it's just not sort of categorically
rigid in the same way that male
sexualities of course we have male
bisexual men too but you're right
they're much more rare than bisexual
females also there's a societal thing
there too that contributes but yeah I
think the societal thing is interesting
as well but there are many guys out
there thinking we all can get our
girlfriends to watch lesbian porn with
us now
many of them yeah uh right yeah no women
love lesbian porn heterosexual women
typically love lesbian porn I mean
objectively the female body is
significantly nicer than the male body
like we got as a man we got so the best
end of the deal
like it's just there is no no you're
just a guy that you're just a guy the
male body well-conditioned male body is
pretty nice you're wrong I hate to tell
you this I know this is a area of
subject anyway did you see Linda
Lindbergh's meta-analysis looking at
this strength of masculinity and
testosterone predicting mating success
and Offspring viability do you see this
when did this come out recently within
the last few months like
uh
uh I don't know I don't agree with you
I'm gonna read you a little okay and put
you on the spot uh here we met our
meta-analyzed the relationships between
six masculine traits and mating slash
reproductive outcomes 96 studies 474
effects an end size of 177 000 voice
pitch height and testosterone all
predicted mating however strength
muscularity it was the strongest and
only consistent predictor of both mating
and reproduction facial masculinity and
digit ratios did not significantly
predict either there was no clear
evidence for any effect of masculinity
on Offspring viability please explain
what the [ __ ] I just read yeah so this
if I so if I'm remembering correctly
um and please correct me if I'm wrong
they looked at all kinds of different
populations right they um looked at
hunter-gatherers right how many
populations did you say they looked at
uh uh 96 studies 474 effects an end size
of 177 000.
um
I can't I I it's hard for me to comment
without going back to look at the study
so they found that facial voice picture
height and testosterone all predicted
mating however strength muscularity was
the strongest and only consistent
predictor of both mating and
reproduction facial masculinity and
digit ratios did not significantly
predict either there was no clear
evidence for any effects of masculinity
oh this makes sense this makes oh on any
measure of masculinity on Osprey
Offspring viability correct
okay so first of all the digit ratio I I
wouldn't have predicted that it would
have any relationship to anything and
that is because a I don't think it's a
great measure of testosterone
um exposure in utero and even if it is
how I'm not even sure how that would
predict
um Offspring survival
other than yeah I'm not sure there'd be
a good relationship
um the other one is masculinity facial
masculinity and I don't see why that
would predict Offspring survival because
good parents don't aren't the ones with
the most uh good Dads aren't the ones
with the most uh masculinized faces in
fact that could be counter to the
outcome for the child because there is
some evidence that facial masculinity is
a product of uh testosterone levels in
puberty and that those guys are in fact
uh a little bit more physically
aggressive which is not necessarily good
for Offspring survival there's other
traits associated with mass facial
masculinity
strength and it was strength strength
and muscularity was the strongest and
only consistent
that makes sense because you have to be
healthy to uh be able to put on that
muscle mass you have to be able to get
resources in the form of energy from
food you have to be able to convert that
into muscle mass and carry that muscle
it means you're not sick means so
healthy strong men are healthy men
um who are socially dominant who can
attain resources and then use those
resources to grow big and strong have
good genes for one thing not only do
they have good genes they're probably
going to be socially dominant that gives
them increased access to resources which
are going to benefit benefit their
um partner and offspring the voice is a
little bit surprising but that did you
say voice is not voice pitch height and
testosterone predicted mating but didn't
predict mating reproduction
it wasn't it was sorry it was the most
consistent that's
um
interesting because
predicted mating meaning number of uh
mates what was the mate I got it see I
haven't looked at I looked at that paper
but very briefly it's fine yeah just um
yeah I mean voice pitch is sexually
attractive to women and it is in some
societies associated with dominance it
may not I don't think that though any of
those characteristics are associated
with uh current testosterone level I
think that like with voice pitch that
really is a function of pubertal
testosterone and that's very important
and I have not seen evidence of the
long-term associations between facial
masculinity voice pitch and I I could be
wrong I don't think I'm wrong about
facial masculinity I think that's really
a function of pubertal testosterone
which can then you know go down a bit or
or vary a bit after puberty is there a
relationship between
pubital testosterone and testosterone
levels throughout the rest of your life
yeah so the the other question I'm just
going to throw in there is is there
really a relationship between prenatal
testosterone which I think is
exceedingly important in shaping not
only male bodies for the rest of their
lives but also their behavior I think
it's potentially even more important
than what happens in puberty
specifically I think it's under really
under appreciated especially in terms of
sex differences so there is no
relationship between
the estimates that we have of prenatal
testosterone and adult testosterone
levels I if I am remembering correctly
there is also not
this sounds wrong to me but I don't uh
and I think I have looked into this and
I'm not sure there's a strong
relationship between pubertal
testosterone and later adult
testosterone but I could be wrong and
someone's going to go look it up and
tell me I'm wrong so I don't want to
assert anything there but I um
I'm not sure there's a strong if there
is a relationship I don't think it's
strong the other element which wasn't
included in this study that I I always
come back to was being absolutely
fascinating is the relationship between
hand grip strength and yeah pretty much
anything that you can care about for men
everything can you explain that yeah
um so I think that hand grip is
interesting because it's not one of the
things that people typically
work on I think it's like a pure index
of the effect of testosterone on
someone's overall strength and it's one
of the best predictors of somebody's
overall strength
um and it's one of the largest sex
differences so uh and that is purely a
function of testosterone differences so
it's not uh I think you can find that a
very strong difference there in con um
where you have equally trained athletes
for instance and you still have the male
grip strength is it 50 or uh maybe even
more yeah I think it couldn't surprise
me if it was more but it's like it's
correlated with
um a number of sexual partners it's the
it's the strongest predictor of the
number of sexual partners yes so it must
be because well I think because you
don't have any other individual yes
um
uh variable from of physical strength
because like in sports
in each sport you're gonna have a
different muscle group that or or
whatever or VO2 or you know where males
have advantage in all of those on
average but it depends on your specific
body type but grip strength is going to
capture all of that in a way that maybe
no other single variable does I didn't
know that grip strength was the bet
would it say that again well I didn't
know that the thing you just said I'm
pretty sure that I'm right when I say
grip strength is the single best
predictor of the total number of mates
that a man has throughout his life what
about money
I mean until I yeah okay is it better
than not like being loaded but I don't
think that you could genetically well
however you would say it's difficult to
test for that in the same way that this
is being tested for I think it's
stripped bare if you were to look at a
man okay if you control for everything
else but also you have a lot of
populations that don't ha accumulate a
lot of resources and mates are being not
being chosen based on uh
a material wealth yes
that is is amazing that's amazing
because it also I mean humans in humans
it's not just
physical strength that confers status
and makes men attractive of course so
that's really interesting so maybe it
co-varies with some other
um genes that are expressed in the brain
that have something to do I think that
you're correct something else that it
correlates with is uh mood stability
over time for men it's that guys is it
an inverse correlation guys that have a
strong positive guys that have a
stronger grip strength report a greater
level of mood uh less depression
and uh okay I gotta uh this is I'll send
stuff over I'll send stuff over once
we've finished it okay and I can no the
grip strength think grip strength thing
is interesting because it was my
understanding that there isn't a huge
testosterone relationship there
I don't know let me let me see I do not
give me one second I mean
okay William I'm on a podcast at the
moment um did you look at that study
around grip strength correlated with uh
male sexual partners throughout life and
I think it was also affect or mental
stability or reported levels of
well-being and depression uh if you can
send this back quickly that would be
appreciated I thank you
uh it's always good to have an
evolutionary psychologist
just on your staff just on hand it's not
on my staff at all he's just a friend
um but he he's always on one side
um but yeah
have you found it
our article aimed to compare the
association between testosterone levels
and grip strength which probably means
they didn't find one or else it would
have been in the abstract or the title
results oh serum testosterone levels I
should know this had a significant
correlation with grip strength in all
models in addition high testosterone
levels were negatively associated with
low muscle strength in all groups oh I
know
um wait no I don't
a strong relationship was observed
between testosterone levels and grip
strength among non-obese participants
yeah I mean that is not that's
interesting because overall muscularity
is not always associated with higher
testosterone it may be within the guy
where you know higher testosterone
levels um for that guy are associated
with higher
um muscularity or or obviously increased
ability to put on muscle but
um Carl hooven ladies and gentlemen uh
if people want to check out the stuff
that you do and follow you online where
should they go
uh Twitter
I am at hoovlet h-o-o-v-l-e-t
and I have a website that I have to
update which is Carol hooven.com
and I'm trying to this is very
embarrassing but figure out how to use
Instagram so I have an Instagram I'm
trying to like start to post things
what is it oh God I don't know come on
Carol the first thing you need to know
about your Instagram is what your
Instagram is okay right I should be
prepared
um it's important Instagram right okay
do I just go to my story how do I get
who I am here it'll it should go in your
profile this is okay
here I'm just gonna what's it say what's
it say at the top
at
Carol dot hooven cool is that what yes
carol.huven at the time and there's me
and Dr Phil you look good Dr Phil looks
good as well
and there's okay is that a doggo you got
a doggo in there
that's my cat oh okay that's my I posted
two pictures of my cat uh not so old
that's dumb all right I Wishful Wishful
identification from me with the with the
cat to dog misgendering there
um and again
yeah all right uh what else are they
gonna say oh what are you working on now
I've heard a rumor I've heard a rumor
that you're working on another book is
that true or not
um
I'm going to be working on another book
I am working on some papers some really
some papers I'm very excited about and
um
I have some things I'm trying to
straight straighten out with my Harvard
part of my life uh so that's taking up
some time
and uh yeah I am I've had a few ideas I
keep changing my mind about the book
that I'm doing next so I've got a uh get
that squared away I'm open to ideas I
really feel like I want to focus on this
issue that we talked about earlier this
um sort of male
uh
I want to focus I think on male
um puberty and not stigmatizing it and
helping writing a book that helps young
men and those around them and women kind
of understand what it might be like and
the challenges that young men have to
face and how we can celebrate this stage
like we do in women and have people feel
uh
happy about like you said it was great I
want I don't I want my son I I want my
son to
have that feeling I don't want him to
get any messages that he's bad for being
yeah I don't want to end by crying but
but that's I that is the book that I'm
have kind of bubbling up well I know
that you spoke to Richard Reeves a
little while ago yeah and uh Richard was
recently on the show and I absolutely
adored his approach structural problems
for of boys and men structural problems
that are being faced by Boys men
families dads so on and so forth and I I
if I was to bet money I'm usually pretty
good at being able to predict Trends I
was a club promoter for a long time and
we basically tell me because I want to
write the book that's going to hit at
the right time so I think it's I think
um looking at a holistic way to
reintroduce masculinity into the
conversation I think is just an absolute
it is science-based way you know that's
that needs to be back I mean Richard did
it from a different way right like he's
a policy one a policy from from
Washington so you speak in the currency
that you have to come into it with like
whatever gravitas you've got you're
going to use it I think I think that
you're perfectly positioned in order to
write a book that discusses what it like
masculinity and becoming a man going
from boy to men
from a biological perspective I I would
I would read the [ __ ] out of that and I
think can I just ask you something about
it yeah of course just and then we can
then we'll go yeah it's funny because I
am outspoken about the science of sex
and gender however I think I'm a little
nervous about writing a book like that
because
and I want not to be nervous at all
um because I think so many people
feel Justified and maybe this is exactly
why I have to write it that so many
people feel Justified and kind of um
stigmatizing male sexuality and that's
so deeply ingrained
and uh I think I'm afraid a little bit
afraid which is weird because I'm
usually not but that's awesome but now
that I'm saying this out loud maybe this
means that I absolutely have to write
that book I think the reason that you're
concerned is a guide toward the fact
that this is something which other
people are also going to be scared about
the fact that other people are going to
be scared makes it less likely that it's
going to be written the fact that I For
What from what I know about the changes
you've made at Harvard over the last few
years it seems like I didn't know
I I here's something I was thinking
about when I was listening to you talk
earlier on um
I don't think that the
Academy can continue running around with
its hands over its eyes
for that much longer
and I think that there's going to be
opportunities for people like Richard
like yourself
to come out and really really push a
great positive message and I think that
at the end of the day the free Market's
going to win with stuff like this like
if you write an absolute storming book
like no one could read Richard's stuff
no one could read of boys and men and go
this is a guy trying to take away
women's rights for themselves so yeah
there's gonna have to be some caveats
and yeah you're gonna have to be more
hyperbolic and a little bit more like
wordy than you need to you know in order
to be able to finagle yourself but I I
think that it would be a very valuable
book and what's the point of spending
all of this time learning all of this
[ __ ] about the way that testosterone
affects people and the upbringing and
going and spending time in Africa and
going and spending time watching [ __ ]
deer fight each other every other season
like
you're the person you're the person to
write the book as far as I can see
you're the person to write the book it's
like maybe this is one of the wars that
you've got maybe this is one of the
hills that you've got to stand on and
there'll be a lot of people that would
be here I'll I'll support you Joe will
support you Richard will support you
tons of people well
I can't just please don't I don't want
to be on there crying that's okay I'll
Dean Dean make sure that the screen goes
dark for a little bit on this no
seriously I really appreciate this and
um you're helping me just talking to you
about it it's sort of convincing me this
is actually what I should do and I've
been dragging my feet putting the
proposal together
but it seems clear uh
let's let's let's leave it there Carol I
appreciate the hell out of you I really
appreciate your work I think you're
incredibly Charming uh thank you for
coming on
thank you so much what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
thank you